What if your laziness isn't a flaw, but
your greatest strength? This perspective
should change the way you look at life.
The most successful people aren't
working hardest, they're working
smartest. Strategic laziness means
directing your limited energy only
toward what truly matters. Consider two
entrepreneurs. One works 80 hours weekly
on everything. The other focuses only on
high impact
activities. 6 months later, guess who's
thriving while the other burns out. It's
not about effort, it's about leverage.
The 8020 rule proves 80% of your results
come from just 20% of your actions. This
isn't just theory. It's a universal law.
Every decision drains mental energy.
That's why productivity hacks eventually
fail. Your environment always beats
willpower. Small changes to your
environment lead to massive behavior
changes. Goals are for amateurs. Systems
are for professionals. Systems succeed
where willpower fails. The ambitious but
lazy builds assets that work while they
sleep, breaking free from trading time
for money. That's not just a dream. It's
entirely possible. Being ambitious but
lazy isn't a contradiction. It's a
superpower when harnessed correctly.